(explosives firing)
- [Narrator] This March 3rd video shows
civilian vehicles being
fired on while fleeing
the occupied Ukrainian
village of Motyzhyn.
Located outside of Kyiv between
Motyzhyn and Yasnohorodka,
a roughly four mile stretch
of road served as a crucial
but perilous escape route
from incoming Russian forces.
Local police said 37
civilians died here between
late February and the end of March.
The Wall Street Journal
analyzed videos, photos,
messages posted to social
media and weapon debris.
We interviewed multiple
people in the village
and reviewed phone
calls between residents.
We didn't account for all of the deaths,
but we found evidence
from a few key incidents
that give a window into how
a four mile stretch of road
became one of the most
blatant examples in the war
of Russian soldiers attacking civilians
attempting to flee.
One man who made it
through the road in March,
Yuriy Suprunenko recalled the horror.
- (foreign language).
- [Narrator] There are three main routes
in and out of Motyzhyn.
During the first week of the war,
the two roads to the
north became the site of
many civilian killings
as they tried to flee
Russian forces pushing south.
Many Motyzhyn residents turned
to a road running southeast
toward the village of Yasnohorodka
in hopes of getting to places
free of Russian troops.
But this southern route would become
just as perilous throughout the month.
The stretch of road closer
to Yasnohorodka is where
many civilians were attacked.
On March 3rd a caravan of
three evacuating vehicles
were fired on here.
(explosives firing)
Weapons experts say
that the two projectiles
seen in these videos are likely mortar
and appear from the left of the frame
indicating that they were likely shot from
the northeast side of the
road, just east of Motyzhyn,
which a driver in one of
these vehicles confirmed.
In April we found debris
on the same stretch of road
that experts say is from an 82 millimeter,
or 120 millimeter mortar,
because of the shape of the tail fin
and the markings seen here.
These types of mortars
can be fired from roughly
two to five miles away.
We found evidence of heavy
Russian military activity
in that range throughout the month.
In a March 5th recording shared
with The Wall Street Journal
Yuriy Suprunenko, who was
still in Motyzhyn at the time
called in a Russian firing
location in this area
to a member of the volunteer
Ukrainian military.
- [Yuriy] (foreign language).
- [Narrator] Just to the
west of the firing location
Suprunenko reported, we
can see Russian vehicles
in a drone video from late March.
In a forested area just
north of the Russian vehicles
in early April, The
Wall Street Journal saw
more evidence of Russian troops.
A mass grave and military badges from
the 37th Guards Motor Rifle Brigade.
Residents also said Russian troops
fired on cars from
positions close to the road.
The Russian embassy in Washington DC
didn't respond to requests for comment.
The Kremlin has said previously
it is not targeting civilians.
On March 7th a message posted
in a Motyzhyn Telegram group
warned of a roadblock.
That same day, a civilian
named Oleh Moskalenko
who was traveling towards Motyzhyn
was taken captive at a checkpoint
according to his daughter.
His car was left on the road.
Rocks, likely used to block the road
are visible in videos filmed
in the days that followed.
Moskalenko's friends and family
used the Find My Phone tool
to track his phone.
The last coordinates
point to a line of trees
along the road.
Moskalenko's daughter said
that he was questioned about
being a member of the
Ukrainian forces and beaten.
He was eventually released by the Russians
and is now recovering
in a German hospital.
We can still see Oleh's car on the road in
a March 10th video filmed by evacuees.
We also see another car abandoned nearby
suggesting more civilians
were captured, or fled.
On March 16th a news
video shows a third car
that's been abandoned, a
damaged red station wagon
with a white cloth tied to a side mirror
and a sign in the windshield
that reads "Children"
in Russian and Ukrainian.
Near the vehicles
Ukrainian soldiers discover
the dead body of a local man.
Facebook messages reveal that
a woman driving in the car
was rescued and taken to
the hospital with injuries.
We were unable to determine
whether she ultimately survived.
What Yuriy Suprunenko describes
in the March 17th video
after his escape speaks
to the lasting toll of
Russian brutality on the road.
- (foreign language).